willkommen zurück zu „Quantum Information and Computation verstehen" – mein Name ist John Matus und ich bin technischer Direktor für Bildung bei IBM
Quantum. Das ist die 12. Lektion in der Reihe und die letzte Lektion der dritten Einheit, die sich mit der allgemeinen
Formulierung von Quanteninformation beschäftigt. Diese Lektion dreht sich um einen grundlegenden Begriff der Quanteninformation, nämlich die
Purifikation eines Quantenzustands. Eine Purifikation eines Quantenzustands, der durch eine Dichtemrix dargestellt wird, ist ein
reiner Zustand eines größeren Verbundsystems, der uns den ursprünglichen Zustand liefert, wenn der Rest des Verbundsystems
verworfen oder herausgespurt wird. Jede Dichtematrix hat eine Purifikation, und wir können vieles
über Quantenzustände und Quanteninformation im Allgemeinen lernen, indem wir Purifikationen auf intuitiver Ebene untersuchen.
Quantenzustandsvektoren, die reine Zustände repräsentieren, sind einfachere mathematische Objekte als Dichtematrizen, und indem wir über
Purifikationen von Zuständen nachdenken, können wir beliebige Quantenzustände von Systemen als bloße Teile von etwas Größerem, aber
Einfacherem betrachten. Wir werden auch über die Fidelity zwischen zwei Quantenzuständen sprechen – ein Wert, der ihre
Ähnlichkeit oder Überlappung quantifiziert – und der häufig verwendet wird, um zu messen, wie gut ein bestimmter Zustand im Vergleich zu
einem idealen Zustand ist. Insbesondere werden wir die Definition der Fidelity sowie einige ihrer grundlegenden Eigenschaften besprechen, und wir werden sehen,
wie Fidelity mit Purifikationen zusammenhängt. Hier ist eine Übersicht der Lektion: Wir beginnen mit Purifikationen, einschließlich der
Definition und eines einfachen Beweises ihrer Existenz, der uns zeigt, wie wir eine finden, wenn wir sie brauchen. Dann besprechen wir etwas, das als
Schmidt-Zerlegung eines Quantenzustandsvektors zweier Systeme bekannt ist, und wir werden sehen, wie Schmidt-Zerlegungen mit
Purifikationen zusammenhängen. Dann besprechen wir eine äußerst wichtige Beziehung zwischen zwei beliebigen Purifikationen desselben Zustands, die als unitäre
Äquivalenz von Purifikationen bekannt ist. Abschließend gehen wir einige Beispiele durch. Dann wenden wir uns der Fidelity zu –
ihrer Definition und einigen ihrer grundlegenden Eigenschaften. Wir werden das Gentle-Measurement-Lemma besprechen, eine sehr
praktische Aussage, die Fidelity mit Messungen verknüpft. Zum Abschluss der Lektion wenden wir uns dann dem Uhlmann-Theorem zu, das
eine fundamentale Verbindung zwischen Fidelity und Purifikationen herstellt. Beginnen wir mit der
Definition einer Purifikation. Eine Purifikation eines Zustands, von dem wir annehmen, dass er durch eine Dichte-
matrix dargestellt wird, ist ein reiner Zustand eines größeren Verbundsystems, der den ursprünglichen Zustand, mit dem wir begonnen haben, zurücklässt, wenn der Rest
des Verbundsystems herausgespurt wird. Dies lässt sich präziser in mathematischen Begriffen ausdrücken:
Wenn wir ein System X haben, das sich in einem Zustand ρ befindet – das heißt, ρ ist eine Dichtematrix, die einen Zustand von X darstellt –
und ψ ein Quantenzustandsvektor eines Paares von Systemen XY ist, sodass das Herausspuren von Y aus dem reinen Zustand |ψ⟩⟨ψ|
uns ρ liefert, dann sagen wir, dass ψ eine Purifikation von ρ ist. Natürlich spielen die Namen keine Rolle – wir können
unsere Systeme und Zustände beliebig benennen, und auch die Reihenfolge der Systeme spielt keine Rolle. Wenn zum Beispiel
das System Y links statt rechts stünde, aber sonst alles gleich wäre, würden wir ψ immer noch als Purifikation von ρ bezeichnen. Aber wir werden
für den Rest der Lektion hauptsächlich bei dieser Konvention bleiben, der Einfachheit halber. Das Erste, was zur
Definition zu sagen ist: Purifikationen existieren immer – für jede Dichtematrix ρ. Genauer gesagt: Jede
Dichtematrix ρ hat eine Purifikation wie in der Definition beschrieben, sofern das System Y mindestens so groß wie X ist –
das heißt, Y hat mindestens genauso viele klassische Zustände wie X. Der Begriff der Purifikation und die
Tatsache, dass Purifikationen immer existieren, erweisen sich als äußerst wichtig – und sie gehören auch zu dem, was Quanteninformation so schön macht. Ich hoffe, ich kann
dich bis Ende der Lektion davon überzeugen. Beweisen wir nun, dass jede Dichtematrix eine Purifikation hat – und dabei werden wir sehen, wie
wir uns eine Purifikation beschaffen können, wenn wir eine brauchen. Genau wie in der Definition
einer Purifikation nehmen wir an, dass X ein System ist und ρ eine Dichtematrix, die einen Zustand von
X darstellt. Betrachte nun einen beliebigen Ausdruck von ρ als Konvexkombination reiner Zustände, wie auf dem Bildschirm geschrieben. Mit anderen Worten:
Für eine geeignete Wahl einer positiven ganzen Zahl n haben wir einen Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor p₀ bis p_ sowie Quanten-
zustandsvektoren φ₀ bis φ_, und indem wir die entsprechenden reinen Zustände mit den Wahrscheinlichkeiten gewichtet mitteln,
erhalten wir ρ. Zum Beispiel könnten wir das Spektraltheorem nutzen, um so einen Ausdruck für ρ zu erhalten – und wenn wir das täten,
könnten wir n als die Anzahl der klassischen Zustände von X wählen. Tatsächlich könnten wir n gleich dem Rang von ρ setzen, der
gleich der Anzahl der von null verschiedenen Eigenwerte von ρ ist, wobei jeder entsprechend seiner Vielfachheit gezählt wird – und das
ist nie größer als die Anzahl der klassischen Zustände von X, könnte aber kleiner sein. Andererseits muss das
keine Spektralzerlegung von ρ sein, und die Quantenzustandsvektoren müssen nicht orthogonal sein – zum Beispiel ist jeder solche Ausdruck von ρ
in Ordnung. Und hier ist eine Purifikation von ρ: Die Summe läuft über dieselben Werte wie
in unserem Ausdruck für ρ, und innerhalb der Summe nehmen wir die Quadratwurzeln der Wahrscheinlichkeiten, multipliziert mit φ_a, tensort
mit |k_a⟩. Dabei nehmen wir übrigens an, dass 0 bis n-1 klassische Zustände des zweiten Systems Y sind – es
macht also Sinn, dass ψ ein Quantenzustandsvektor des Paares XY ist, wie in der Definition. Es ist hier eigentlich nicht wichtig,
dass wir Standardbasiszustände von Y in diesem Ausdruck verwenden – du könntest jede beliebige orthonormale Sammlung von
Zuständen anstelle von |k₀⟩ bis |k_⟩ einsetzen, wenn du möchtest. Jetzt können wir überprüfen, dass dies tatsächlich
eine Purifikation ist, indem wir die partielle Spur über Y berechnen. Hier ist ein Ausdruck des Zustands, den wir erhalten, wenn wir die partielle Spur ausführen.
Die Spur von |k_a⟩⟨k_b| ist entweder eins oder null, je nachdem, ob a gleich b ist oder nicht – und so vereinfacht sich der Ausdruck
auf unseren ursprünglichen Ausdruck für ρ. So einfach ist das. Es ist also sehr leicht, eine
Purifikation zu finden, solange wir genug klassische Zustände von Y haben – oder alternativ eine große genug orthonormale Menge, die wir
anstelle der Standardbasiszustände |k₀⟩ bis |k_⟩ verwenden. Übrigens: Wenn die Anzahl der
klassischen Zustände von Y kleiner als der Rang von ρ ist, gibt es keine Purifikation – das überlasse ich dir
zum Nachdenken, wenn du möchtest. Hier ist ein Beispiel. Betrachten wir
die Dichtematrix, die wir in der Lektion über Dichtematrizen mehrfach gesehen haben. Hier haben wir einen Ausdruck dieser
Dichtematrix als Konvexkombination reiner Zustände – es ist keine Spektralzerlegung, aber das
spielt keine Rolle. Mit kaum einem Aufwand können wir eine Purifikation des Zustands aufschreiben, indem wir dem
Rezept folgen. Das ist nicht die einzige Purifikation dieser Dichtematrix – Purifikationen sind nicht eindeutig, aber das ist in Ordnung. Die
Die Definition sagt nichts über Eindeutigkeit aus, und tatsächlich gibt es eine sehr interessante Beziehung zwischen verschiedenen Purifikationen desselben Zustands, aber
das werden wir später in der Lektion noch etwas besprechen. Als Nächstes betrachten wir Schmid-Zerlegungen, das sind Darstellungen von
bipartiten Quanten-Zustandsvektoren in einer bestimmten Form, die ich gleich beschreiben werde. Sie sind nach Erhard
Schmidt benannt, demselben Schmidt, der für das Graham-Schmidt-Orthogonalisierungsverfahren bekannt ist. Im Fall der Schmid-Zerlegungen sollten sie jedoch eigentlich nicht
nach Schmidt benannt sein. Es ist mathematisch äquivalent zu etwas, das man die Singulärwertzerlegung für Matrizen nennt, die
tatsächlich mehrfach unabhängig entdeckt wurde. Das passiert aber manchmal. Wie auch immer, hier ist, was wir meinen,
wenn wir von einer Schmid-Zerlegung sprechen: Für eine beliebige Wahl eines Quanten-Zustandsvektors s für ein Paar von
Systemen XY ist es immer möglich, s in einer speziellen Form zu schreiben. Diese Form lautet, wie wir
hier auf dem Bildschirm sehen, wobei R eine positive ganze Zahl ist, p 0 bis p r minus eins positive reelle Zahlen sind, die
zusammen einen Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor bilden; x0 bis XR minus1 sind Einheitsvektoren, die dem System X entsprechen, und y0
bis y rus1 sind Einheitsvektoren, die dem System y entsprechen. Das mag vielleicht nicht besonders
auffällig erscheinen, bis ich dir sage, dass sowohl die Menge x0 bis XR minus eins als auch y0 bis y Rus eins
orthonormal sein müssen. Warum ist das besonders? Wenn wir eine beliebige Basis für eine der beiden Basen wählen würden – sagen wir
die X-Vektoren, die dem System X entsprechen –, dann könnten wir s immer in dieser Form ausdrücken, und das würde uns dazu zwingen,
die Y-Vektoren auf eine bestimmte Weise zu wählen. Das machen wir eigentlich recht routinemäßig, wie bei einer Standardbasis, wenn wir uns darauf vorbereiten,
eine Standardbasismessung zu analysieren. Aber im Allgemeinen werden die Y-Vektoren, die wir erhalten, selbst wenn wir eine Orthonormalbasis für die X-
Vektoren wählen, nicht notwendigerweise orthonormal sein. Ebenso würde es nicht funktionieren, wenn du eine
Orthonormalbasis für die Y-Vektoren wählst und versuchst, s wieder in dieser Form auszudrücken – du könntest es, aber die X-Vektoren wären dann nicht
notwendigerweise orthonormal. Und schließlich, wenn du für beide Systeme orthonormale Vektoren wählst und
versuchst, s in einer solchen Form auszudrücken, würde es nicht unbedingt funktionieren, weil du möglicherweise Kreuzterme benötigst. Aber es gibt nur einen
Index in dieser Summe, nämlich a. Die Form ist also besonders, aber es ist immer möglich,
einen gegebenen Einheitsvektor s so zu schreiben. Und hier ist, wie du das tun kannst: Berechne zunächst eine Spektralzerlegung
des reduzierten Zustands eines der beiden Systeme – es spielt keine Rolle welches. Um aber zu beschreiben, wie das geht, schauen wir uns den reduzierten Zustand von
X an. Wir spurausrechnen also y heraus. Das bedeutet, dass p 0 bis p r minus eins die Eigen-
werte dieses reduzierten Zustands rho sind, und x0 bis XR minus eins sind Einheits-Eigenvektoren, die diesen Eigenwerten entsprechen. Und
übrigens: Das Verständnis hierbei ist, dass wir die Terme ignorieren, für die die Eigenwerte null sind, weil diese Terme nichts zur
Summe beitragen. Das heißt, p 0 bis p r minus eins sind allesamt positive reelle Zahlen, und R ist die Anzahl der Nicht-Null-
Eigenwerte unter Berücksichtigung der Vielfachheiten, was gleich dem Rang von rho ist. Das liefert uns p 0 bis p r
minus eins sowie x0 bis XR minus eins. Alles, was noch bleibt, ist, die Vektoren y0 bis y Rus
eins zu finden. Es gibt nur eine Wahl, die möglicherweise funktionieren kann. Diese Vektoren sind an diesem Punkt eindeutig bestimmt und können
leicht mithilfe der einfachen Formel gefunden werden, die auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird. Und das Erstaunliche hier ist, dass,
wenn wir diese Vektoren auf diese Weise definieren, sie garantiert orthonormal sind. Das liefert uns eine Schmid-Zerlegung. Ich werde das in diesem
Video nicht beweisen, aber es ist nicht allzu schwierig, und du kannst das schriftliche Material zur Lektion konsultieren, falls du interessiert bist. Schau dir
die Videobeschreibung für einen Link an, wie üblich. Als Beispiel betrachten wir diesen
Quanten-Zustandsvektor, den wir als Purifikation des Dichtematrix-Beispiels erhalten haben, auf das wir immer wieder zurückkommen.
Es ist keine Schmid-Zerlegung, weil der Null- und der Plus-Zustand nicht orthonormal sind, aber wir können eine finden,
indem wir das Verfahren verwenden, das ich gerade beschrieben habe. Der erste Schritt besteht darin, eine Spektralzerlegung für den reduzierten
Zustand von X zu berechnen, also dasselbe Beispiel einer Dichtematrix. Und hier ist eine Spektralzerlegung davon, die wir früher
in Lektion 9 gesehen haben. Wir wählen also p 0, P1, x0 und X1 wie
auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt. p 0 und P1 sind die Eigenwerte von rho, und x0 und X1 sind
entsprechende Einheits-Eigenvektoren. Es bleibt also, y0 und y1 zu berechnen. Wenn wir das tun, erhalten wir Ket Plus
für y0 und -1 mal Ket minus für y1. Das ist nicht unmittelbar offensichtlich – du musst
die Rechnung tatsächlich durchführen, um es zu sehen. Aber das ist, was wir erhalten. Und wie erwartet sind diese beiden Vektoren orthonormal,
wie es immer der Fall sein wird, wenn du die Berechnungen korrekt durchgeführt hast. Das liefert uns eine Schmid-Zer-
legung. Schmid-Zerlegungen sind in vielen Situationen sehr nützlich, und bald werden wir sehen, was sie uns
über Purifikationen sagen. Purifikationen sind nicht eindeutig. Ein gegebener Quantenzustand, dargestellt
durch eine Dichtematrix, hat tatsächlich unendlich viele Purifikationen. Es gibt jedoch eine enge
Beziehung, die immer zwischen je zwei Purifikationen desselben Zustands gilt. Sie wird manchmal als die unitäre
Äquivalenz von Purifikationen bezeichnet. So funktioniert es: Sei rho eine Dichtematrix,
die einen Quantenzustand des Systems X darstellt. Angenommen, wir haben zwei beliebige Purifikationen dieses Zustands, die
reine Zustände desselben zusammengesetzten Systems sind. Zur Konkretisierung nehmen wir an, dass s und fi
Quanten-Zustandsvektoren eines Paares von Systemen XY sind, die beide rho ergeben, wenn das System Y herausgespurt wird.
Was die unitäre Äquivalenz der Purifikation besagt, ist, dass es eine unitäre Operation U geben muss, die nur auf
das System y wirkt und SII in fi transformiert. Mit anderen Worten: Obwohl diese
beliebigen Purifikationen von rho sind und wir nichts über sie annehmen außer dass sie beide rho purifikieren und
beide Zustände desselben zusammengesetzten Systems XY sind, müssen sie in gewissem Sinne äquivalent sein – bis auf eine unitäre Operation auf y
allein. Wir werden ein paar Beispiele sehen, die veranschaulichen, warum das interessant ist und welche Implikationen es hat. Aber zuerst wollen wir
sehen, warum es wahr ist. Beginnen wir mit einer Spektralzerlegung von rho, das ist die
Dichtematrix, die sowohl SII als auch fi purifikation sind. Und genau wie wir es bei der Schmid-Zerlegung gemacht haben,
nehmen wir an, dass wir alle Terme verworfen haben, die den Null-Eigenwerten entsprechen. So sind p 0 bis p r minus1
allesamt positive reelle Zahlen, x0 bis XR minus eins sind orthonormale Eigenvektoren von rho, und R ist
Rang der Zeile – und übrigens: beachte, wie oft wir an diesem Punkt auf das Spektraltheorem zurückgreifen
es ist ein unglaublich praktisches Werkzeug, und tatsächlich wären wir ohne es verloren – wie auch immer, da wir jetzt eine Spektral-
Zerlegung der Zeile haben, können wir Schmidt-Zerlegungen unserer beiden Vektoren berechnen, genau wie zuvor, und sie werden
fast exakt gleich sein: die Koeffizienten und die X-Vektoren sind dieselben, da sie aus der Spektralzerlegung des reduzierten Zustands stammen, der
für beide Vektoren gleich ist – der einzige Unterschied ist, dass wir möglicherweise unterschiedliche Vektoren für das zweite System erhalten. Für den
ersten Vektor, das ist s, erhalten wir einen Satz von Vektoren y0 bis y_, und für den zweiten Vektor, das ist f, erhalten wir
eine möglicherweise andere Sammlung, die wir z0 bis z_ nennen können. Wir haben also jetzt Schmidt-Zerlegungen
für unsere beiden Vektoren, die sehr ähnlich aussehen, außer dass die Vektoren für das zweite System unterschiedlich sein können. Da dies aber
Schmidt-Zerlegungen sind, sind diese beiden Sammlungen beide orthonormal, sodass wir einfach
eine unitäre Matrix U wählen können, die ya für jedes a auf za abbildet – das ist immer möglich: unitäre
Operationen sind nämlich äquivalent zu linearen Abbildungen, die eine orthonormale Basis in eine andere überführen. Und wenn
diese beiden Mengen nicht zufällig den gesamten Raum von Y aufspannen, können wir beide stets zu orthonormalen
Basen erweitern – passenderweise mithilfe des Gram-Schmidt-Orthogonalisierungsverfahrens. Und so wird die unitäre
Äquivalenz von Purifikationen bewiesen. In Lektion vier der Reihe haben wir das Superdense-Coding-Protokoll besprochen,
das einem Sender ermöglicht, zwei klassische Bits an einen Empfänger zu übertragen, indem er ein qubit sendet – zu den Kosten eines ebits an
geteilter Verschränkung. Ich setze also voraus, dass du mit diesem Protokoll bereits vertraut bist, und der Punkt dieses Beispiels ist, kurz zu
erläutern, wie es mit der unitären Äquivalenz von Purifikationen zusammenhängt. Erinnere dich, dass
das Protokoll so funktioniert: Alice und Bob teilen ein ebit, also einen Phi-Plus-Bell-Zustand. Alice wählt, diesen
Bell-Zustand je nach den zwei Bits, die sie senden möchte, in einen der vier Bell-Zustände umzuwandeln, und sendet dann ihr
qubit an Bob, der misst, welchen Bell-Zustand er hat. Beachte, dass alle vier Bell-Zustände
den gleichen reduzierten Zustand für Bobs qubit ergeben, nämlich den vollständig gemischten Zustand – und das reicht tatsächlich schon aus,
um zu schlussfolgern, dass Superdense Coding möglich ist: Alle vier Bell-Zustände purified den vollständig gemischten Zustand, also folgt aus der unitären
Äquivalenz von Purifikationen, dass es möglich sein muss, dass Alice den Phi-Plus-Bell-Zustand in jeden
der anderen umwandeln kann, indem sie eine unitäre Operation auf ihr qubit anwendet. Natürlich ist es nicht schwer, unitäre Operationen zu finden, die
tatsächlich funktionieren, und sie sind sehr einfach – aber es ist dennoch interessant, dass wir die Schlussfolgerung ziehen können, dass dies
möglich ist, ohne überhaupt über die unitären Operationen selbst nachzudenken. Und darüber hinaus können wir schlussfolgern,
dass Verallgemeinerungen von Superdense Coding auf größere Systeme möglich sind, vorausgesetzt, wir haben eine Möglichkeit, die Bell-Zustände auf größere
Systeme zu verallgemeinern, sodass sie alle den vollständig gemischten Zustand als Bobs reduzierten Zustand ergeben – und es gibt tatsächlich verschiedene bekannte Möglichkeiten,
das zu tun. Ein weiteres Anwendungsgebiet, für das die unitäre Äquivalenz von Purifikationen Konsequenzen hat, ist die Quanten-
kryptographie – und eine ihrer wichtigsten Konsequenzen ist, dass sie die Existenz eines bedingungslos sicheren Quanten-Protokolls für ein
kryptographisches Primitiv namens Bit-Commitment ausschließt. Was ist also Bit-Commitment? Bit-Commitment ist ein Beispiel
für ein kryptographisches Primitiv, womit wir eine einfache Aufgabe oder ein Verfahren meinen, das eine grundlegende Funktionalität bereitstellt, die
dann als Baustein verwendet werden kann, um interessantere Dinge zu tun, wie das Erstellen digitaler Signaturverfahren oder den Aufbau von
Zero-Knowledge-Protokollen. Im Falle von Bit-Commitment besteht die grundlegende Funktionalität darin, dass ein
Spieler, Alice, sich gegenüber einem zweiten Spieler, Bob, auf einen binären Wert ihrer Wahl festlegen kann, ihre Wahl aber verborgen bleibt,
bis sie sich entscheidet, sie zu enthüllen. Wir fordern zwei spezifische Eigenschaften von einem Protokoll, das Bit-
Commitment implementiert: Es muss bindend sein, was bedeutet, dass Alice ihre Meinung nicht ändern kann, sobald sie sich auf ein Bit festgelegt hat. Und es
muss verbergend sein, was bedeutet, dass Bob Alices Bit nicht bestimmen kann, bis sie sich entscheidet, es zu enthüllen.
Es wäre also ziemlich schön, dieses Primitiv mit Quanteninformation implementieren zu können, da es ein
nützliches Primitiv ist – aber ohne zusätzliche Annahmen stellt sich heraus, dass es unmöglich ist, es mit Quanteninformation perfekt oder auch nur annähernd
perfekt umzusetzen. Die unitäre Äquivalenz von Purifikationen zeigt, dass die Idee auf sehr hohem Niveau ist:
Wenn es ein Quanten-Protokoll für Bit-Commitment gäbe, dann müsste es eine sogenannte purified Version dieses Protokolls geben, bei der wir uns vorstellen können, dass
Alice ein System A und Bob ein System B hat, und nachdem die Festlegung gemacht wurde, aber bevor Alice enthüllt, befindet sich das Paar AB in
einem von zwei reinen Zuständen, Psi-null oder Psi-eins, abhängig vom Bit, auf das Alice sich
festgelegt hat. Wenn das Protokoll perfekt verbergend ist, muss es sein, dass Bob keinen Unterschied zwischen den
beiden Festlegungen erkennen kann, also muss sein reduzierter Zustand für beide Möglichkeiten gleich sein. Das impliziert jedoch
durch die unitäre Äquivalenz von Purifikationen, dass Alice einen in den anderen umwandeln kann, indem sie eine unitäre
Operation auf A allein anwendet – das Protokoll ist also vollständig gescheitert, bindend zu sein. Es gibt Details, die ich
übergangen habe, aber der Kern der Sache ist, dass die unitäre Äquivalenz von Purifikationen uns sagt, dass dieses Primitiv nichts ist,
das wir mit Quanteninformation zuverlässig implementieren können, ohne zusätzliche Annahmen irgendeiner
Art. Das letzte Beispiel für eine Konsequenz der unitären Äquivalenz von Purifikationen ist ein Theorem, bekannt als das
Hughston-Jozsa-Wootters-Theorem, oder kurz HJW-Theorem. Beginnen wir mit einer Formulierung des
Theorems selbst – und das ist eine leicht vereinfachte Version davon, um einige technische Details zu vermeiden, damit wir uns auf die wichtigsten
Ideen konzentrieren können. Angenommen, X und Y sind Systeme und F ist ein beliebiger Quanten-Zustandsvektor, der einen reinen Zustand des Paares
XY darstellt. Und nun angenommen, wir betrachten den reduzierten Zustand des Systems X allein und überlegen uns eine beliebige Art,
diesen reduzierten Zustand als Konvexkombination reiner Zustände auszudrücken, wie auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt.
Zum Beispiel kann die Zahl N in diesem Ausdruck, also die Anzahl der reinen Zustände, über die wir mitteln,
beliebig groß sein – möglicherweise viel größer als die Dimension des Raums von X oder von Y. Und
was das Theorem uns sagt, ist, dass eine Messung auf dem System Y mit n Ergebnissen existieren muss, sodass
Folgendes passiert, wenn das System Y gemessen wird: Erstens erscheint jedes Messergebnis
mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit, die genau der entsprechenden Wahrscheinlichkeit in unserem Ausdruck des reduzierten Zustands von X als
Konvexkombination reiner Zustände entspricht. Und zweitens: Bedingt auf ein bestimmtes Messergebnis ist der
der Zustand von X wird zum entsprechenden reinen Zustand aus der konvexen Kombination – warum ist das
interessant? Nun, es bedeutet, dass für jede Art, wie wir den reduzierten Zustand von X als konvexe
Kombination reiner Zustände betrachten wollen, es eine Messung von Y gibt, die diese Sichtweise auf den reduzierten Zustand von X
zur Realität macht – und was bemerkenswert ist: das ist möglich, selbst wenn der Zustand f zuerst gewählt wird und die konvexe
Kombination später gewählt wird, solange sie ein Ausdruck des reduzierten Zustands von X ist, wird es eine
Messung von Y geben, die genau so funktioniert – sehen wir uns also an, wie wir das beweisen können.
Wir beginnen mit zwei verschiedenen Ausdrücken für den Reduzierten von X, dem wir der Einfachheit halber den Namen Rho geben.
Als nächstes führen wir ein neues System Z ein, dessen klassische Zustände die möglichen Messergebnisse sind – oder
gleichwertig die Indizes in unserer konvexen Kombination – und jetzt können wir beobachten, dass die folgenden zwei Quantenzustandsvektoren
Gamma 0 und Gamma 1, die beide Zustandsvektoren für das zusammengesetzte System XYZ sind,
beide Purifizierungen von Rho sind – und nur zur Klarstellung: wenn wir diese Vektoren als Purifizierungen von Rho betrachten,
denken wir dabei an die Systeme Y und Z zusammen als ein einzelnes zusammengesetztes System, das herausgespurt wird, um
Rho zu hinterlassen. Der erste Vektor Gamma 0 ist im Wesentlichen dasselbe wie der ursprüngliche reine Zustand Phi, außer dass wir
das neue System Z auf den Nullzustand initialisieren. Es ist klar, dass wenn wir Y und Z herausspuren, wir Rho übrig haben – also ist Gamma
0 eine Purifizierung von Rho. Der zweite Vektor Gamma 1 ist im Grunde der Vektor, den wir erhalten, wenn wir
Rho anhand der konvexen Kombination purifizieren, genau wie ich es früher in der Lektion beschrieben habe. Diesmal wird das System Y
initialisiert, und ich nehme der Einfachheit halber an, dass Null ein klassischer Zustand von Y ist – aber du könntest jeden
Standardbasiszustand oder tatsächlich jeden reinen Zustand von Y in diesen Ausdruck einsetzen, und es würde keinen Unterschied machen. In jedem Fall hinterlässt das Herausspuren von Y und
Z wieder Rho – also ist das Fazit, dass diese beiden Purifizierungen von Rho sind, und daher durch
die unitäre Äquivalenz der Purifizierungen gibt es eine unitäre Operation U auf dem Paar YZ, die Gamma 0 in
Gamma 1 transformiert – und das ist alles, was wir brauchen, um eine Beschreibung einer Messung zu entwickeln, die das tut, was das Theorem
besagt. Eine einfache Möglichkeit, es zu beschreiben, ist mit einem circuit-Diagramm wie es hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird. Mit Worten: wir beginnen mit dem
Zustand F, führen Z initialisiert auf den Nullzustand ein, führen U aus und messen dann das obere System, also Z, mit einer
Standardbasismessung. Was das effektiv tut, ist Phi in Gamma Eins zu transformieren, und
allein durch Betrachtung der Beschreibung von Gamma 1 können wir sehen, dass dies das tut, was das Theorem besagt – nämlich dass wir
jedes Ergebnis a mit Wahrscheinlichkeit PA erhalten, und bedingt darauf, a zu erhalten, wird das System X im Zustand sa hinterlassen.
Und nur zur Klarstellung: die Messung selbst, deren Existenz das Theorem impliziert, wird durch
alles im gepunkteten Rechteck in der Abbildung implementiert. Und wenn du wissen möchtest, wie die
Messung als eine Sammlung von Matrizen beschrieben werden kann, hier ist ein Ausdruck davon. Ich werde diesen Teil nicht erklären, und es ist
für das Beispiel auch nicht wirklich wichtig – aber das ist ein Ausdruck der Messmatrizen, falls es dich
interessiert. Als nächstes werden wir die Fidelität besprechen, die ein Maß dafür ist, wie ähnlich zwei Quantenzustände sind, oder alternativ, wie
stark sie sich überlappen. Wir beginnen mit der Definition, die auf den ersten
Blick etwas mysteriös wirken mag, aber wir werden sie entschlüsseln, und am Ende der Diskussion hoffe ich, dich davon überzeugt zu haben, dass sie
tatsächlich eine viel schönere Funktion ist, als sie auf den ersten Blick erscheinen mag. Und hier ist die
Definition: die Fidelität zwischen zwei Dichtematrizen Rho und Sigma ist gleich der Spur der Quadratwurzel der
Quadratwurzel von Rho mal Sigma mal der Quadratwurzel von Rho. Wir werden darüber sprechen –
zuerst versuchen wir einfach, der Definition selbst einen Sinn zu geben. Wir haben drei Quadratwurzeln, und
sie beziehen sich alle auf die Quadratwurzel einer positiv semidefiniten Matrix, die, wie wir in der vorherigen Lektion besprochen haben,
die eindeutige positiv semidefinite Matrix ist, die quadriert ergibt, welche Matrix auch immer wir die Quadratwurzel nehmen, weil
Rho eine Dichtematrix ist und daher positiv semidefinit sein muss, können wir ihre Wurzel nehmen, und wenn wir an die Wurzel von Rho mal
Sigma mal Rho einen Moment denken, sehen wir, dass sie auch positiv semidefinit ist, und insbesondere können wir sie schreiben als
M* mal M für M als die Quadratwurzel von Sigma mal der Quadratwurzel von Rho, und daher können wir die Quadrat-
wurzel davon nehmen. Insbesondere können wir eine Spektralzerlegung der Wurzel von
Rho mal Sigma mal der Wurzel von Rho berechnen, und um dann die Quadratwurzel zu nehmen, müssen wir nur die Quadratwurzeln der Eigen-
werte nehmen und die Eigenvektoren unverändert lassen. Und schließlich nehmen wir die Spur dieser
Matrix, und weil die Spur gleich der Summe der Eigenwerte ist, erhalten wir den Ausdruck, den wir hier genau
haben. Das ist also wahrscheinlich etwas, das du im Allgemeinen nicht von Hand berechnen möchtest, und diese Erklärung bietet möglicherweise nicht viel
Einblick in die Fidelität oder warum wir uns darum kümmern – aber hoffentlich klärt sie die technische
Bedeutung der Formel. Übrigens, nur als Randbemerkung: manchmal definieren Leute die Fidelität als
das Quadrat der Funktion, die ich hier definiert habe, und sie bezeichnen diese Funktion als die Wurzel-
Fidelität. Du wirst sie auf beide Arten definiert sehen, was sicherlich das Potenzial hat, Verwirrung zu stiften – aber normalerweise tut es das nicht,
weil die Leute im Allgemeinen ziemlich sorgfältig sind, klar zu machen, welche Definition sie verwenden, und du solltest
darauf achten, dasselbe zu tun. Nach meinem Dafürhalten gibt es wirklich keine richtige oder falsche Definition – ich definiere sie
so, einfach weil ich mich daran gewöhnt habe, es so zu machen, und ich finde es tatsächlich ein wenig praktischer – ich schätze, weil ich lieber etwas quadriere,
als später, wenn der Bedarf entsteht, eine Quadratwurzel zu nehmen. Aber natürlich steht es dir frei, deine eigene
Wahl zu treffen. Wie auch immer, lass mich zur Fidelität zurückkehren, wie sie hier definiert ist. Es gibt andere äquivalente Arten,
die Fidelität zu definieren, und es ist tatsächlich eine ziemlich bemerkenswerte Funktion in dieser Hinsicht – und sie kann tatsächlich auf einige ziemlich interessante
Weisen charakterisiert werden. Hier ist eine ziemlich unkomplizierte Möglichkeit, die Definition in Bezug auf die Spurnorm umzuschreiben, die wir gegen Ende
der vorherigen Lektion gesehen haben. Ich bin nicht zu sehr ins Detail der Spurnorm eingegangen, und insbesondere habe ich
sie nicht einmal für nicht-hermitesche Matrizen definiert – aber sie hat eine einfach genug Definition. Eine Möglichkeit, die Spurnorm einer
beliebigen Matrix M zu definieren, ist, dass sie die Spur der Quadratwurzel von M mal M Dagger ist, oder gleichwertig die Spur der Quadrat-
der Wurzel aus M Dagger mal M erhältst du in beiden Fällen denselben Wert, und wir können diese Definition nutzen, um die
Definition der Fidelity zu vereinfachen, wie hier unten auf dem Bildschirm zu sehen, was schön ist, weil es zeigt, dass
sie symmetrisch in den beiden Argumenten ist. Wir können die Spurennorm einer quadratischen Matrix M auch ausdrücken als das
Maximum des Absolutwerts der Spur von M * U, wobei U über alle unitären Matrizen läuft – was nicht offensichtlich ist, aber
wahr ist, und das gibt uns einen weiteren Ausdruck für die Fidelity. Hier haben wir also drei
äquivalente Definitionen der Fidelity, und das ist erst der Anfang – es gibt noch weitere äquivalente Definitionen, und
wir werden gegen Ende der Lektion eine besonders wichtige kennenlernen, die aus dem Satz von Uhlmann stammt.
Okay, das ist alles schön und gut, aber was bedeutet das auf einer intuitiven Ebene, und warum sollten wir uns für diese
Funktion interessieren? Um diese Fragen zu beantworten, ist es hilfreich, den Spezialfall zu betrachten, in dem mindestens eine der beiden Dichtematrizen
einen reinen Zustand darstellt. Wenn beide Zustände rein sind, dann ist die
Fidelity einfach der Absolutwert des inneren Produkts zwischen den beiden Quantenzustandsvektoren, und in gewisser Weise
ist das eine grundlegende Motivation für die Fidelity selbst. Der Absolutwert des inneren Produkts zwischen zwei Quantenzustandsvektoren
ist immer eine Zahl zwischen null und eins und gibt uns eine natürliche Möglichkeit zu messen, wie viel Überlappung es
zwischen zwei Quantenzustandsvektoren gibt. Die Fidelity kannst du dir als eine nützliche und gut verhaltene Methode vorstellen,
diese Messung der Überlappung von reinen Zuständen auf Dichtematrizen zu erweitern. Wenn einer der Zustände rein ist
und der andere nicht notwendigerweise rein, dann haben wir wiederum einen einfachen Ausdruck für die Fidelity, der recht
praktisch ist, und dieser Ausdruck wird hier gezeigt. Die Fidelity hat viele interessante
Eigenschaften, und das ist einer der Gründe, warum sie verwendet wird. Sie hat eine Definition, die nicht wirklich
besonders schön ist, aber sie ist dennoch eine sehr nützliche Funktion, und sie ist oft sehr einfach zu verwenden, teilweise aufgrund ihrer vielen
erstaunlichen Eigenschaften. Schauen wir uns also einige davon an, beginnend mit der Beobachtung, dass die Fidelity zwischen zwei Dichtematrizen
immer eine Zahl zwischen 0 und eins ist. Sie ist null genau dann, wenn die Zustände
orthogonal sind, was bedeutet, dass die Bilder orthogonale Unterräume sind, oder äquivalent dazu, dass das Produkt der beiden Matrizen
null ist. Und die Fidelity ist eins genau dann, wenn die beiden Dichtematrizen gleich sind. Jeder andere Fall liegt irgendwo dazwischen,
aber intuitiv gesprochen gilt: je näher die Fidelity an eins liegt, desto ähnlicher sind die Zustände, oder alternativ
desto mehr überlappen sie sich. Die Fidelity ist außerdem symmetrisch – das habe ich vor einigen Momenten erwähnt. Es ist
aus dem Ausdruck, den wir für die Fidelity in Bezug auf die Spurennorm gesehen haben, ziemlich klar, aber es ist trotzdem wichtig, das zu erkennen.
Als nächstes ist die Fidelity multiplikativ für Produktzustände, was bedeutet, dass die Fidelity zwischen zwei
Produktzuständen immer gleich dem Produkt der Fidelities zwischen den einzelnen
Zuständen ist. Hier ist eine wirklich nützliche Eigenschaft: Wenn wir zwei beliebige Dichtematrizen gleicher Größe haben
zusammen mit einem beliebigen Kanal, der diese Dichtematrizen als Eingabe nimmt, kann die Fidelity nur größer werden, wenn dieser Kanal
auf beide Zustände angewendet wird. Mit anderen Worten können Kanäle in Bezug auf die Fidelity Zustände nur
einander ähnlicher machen, nicht unähnlicher. Und schließlich – zumindest für diese Liste –
gibt es eine ziemlich enge Beziehung zwischen der Fidelity und der Spurenabstandsdistanz zwischen Zuständen, die definiert ist als
die Hälfte der Spurennorm der Differenz zwischen den beiden Dichtematrizen. Der Spurenabstand zwischen zwei
Zuständen steht in engem Zusammenhang damit, wie gut wir sie unterscheiden können – das haben wir in der vorherigen Lektion im Kontext der
Zustandsunterscheidung und dem Helstrom-Holevo-Theorem besprochen. Während die Fidelity quantifiziert, wie sehr sich zwei Zustände
überlappen. Obwohl sie also nicht genau dasselbe sind, ist es nicht überraschend, dass es eine Beziehung zwischen diesen
beiden Größen gibt. Aber die Ungleichungen, die typischerweise als die Fuchs-van-de-Graaf-Ungleichungen bezeichnet werden, machen
diese Beziehung mathematisch präzise, und es ist ziemlich wichtig, dass hier absolut keine Abhängigkeit von der Größe des Systems besteht, über das wir sprechen.
Wir können diese Beziehung mit Hilfe einer Abbildung etwas deutlicher sehen. Wenn wir zwei Zustände haben und
den Spurenabstand zwischen ihnen auf der x-Achse und die Fidelity auf der y-Achse anordnen, dann müssen sich die entsprechenden vertikalen
und horizontalen Linien irgendwo innerhalb dieser grauen Region schneiden. Der interessanteste Bereich des
Diagramms – zumindest in der Praxis – ist übrigens die obere linke Ecke der grauen Region. Insbesondere wenn der
Spurenabstand sehr klein ist, muss die Fidelity sehr nahe an eins liegen und umgekehrt.
Diese Ungleichungen werden sehr häufig verwendet, und ein Teil des Grundes dafür ist, dass uns letztlich oft mehr
der Spurenabstand interessiert, da er eine natürliche Interpretation in Verbindung mit der Quantenzustandsunterscheidung hat.
Aber die Fidelity hat so viele erstaunliche Eigenschaften, dass sie im Allgemeinen einfacher zu handhaben ist, und solange wir uns in der oberen linken Ecke
der grauen Region befinden – was oft der Fall ist – verlieren wir nicht viel, wenn wir zwischen der Fidelity und dem Spurenabstand hin und her konvertieren. Das sind also
einige der Eigenschaften der Fidelity. Es gibt noch viel mehr, aber das ist ein guter Anfang, und hoffentlich hilft die Liste dabei,
ein gewisses Gespür für die Fidelity zu entwickeln. Hier ist ein schönes Beispiel dafür, wie wir
die Fidelity mit nicht-destruktiven Messungen verbinden können. Es ist ein sehr nützliches Resultat, bekannt als das Gentle-Measurement-
Lemma. Angenommen, wir haben ein System X, einen durch eine Dichtematrix Rho dargestellten Zustand von X und eine Messung am System X,
die durch eine Sammlung positiv semidefiniter Matrizen beschrieben wird. Angenommen, eines der Messergebnisse ist sehr wahrscheinlich
aufzutreten, wenn wir die Messung am Zustand Rho durchführen würden. Der Einfachheit halber nehmen wir an,
dass es das Ergebnis Z ist, das sehr wahrscheinlich ist, und insbesondere nehmen wir an, dass dieses Ergebnis mit
einer Wahrscheinlichkeit größer als 1 minus Epsilon für einen kleinen Wert von Epsilon auftritt – wir müssen Epsilon nicht genauer angeben.
Epsilon ist einfach eine kleine positive reelle Zahl. Wir haben unsere Messung jetzt so beschrieben, als wäre sie eine destruktive
Messung, aber wir wissen aus der vorherigen Lektion, dass wir diese Messung auf eine nicht-destruktive Weise implementieren könnten, und zwar speziell so, wie
wir es in unserer Diskussion des Naimark-Theorems gesehen haben. Das funktioniert folgendermaßen: Jedes Ergebnis a tritt mit
einer Wahrscheinlichkeit auf, die gleich der Spur von PA * Rho ist, und bedingt auf dieses Ergebnis ändert sich der Zustand von X.
Insbesondere ändert sich der Zustand für das wahrscheinliche Ergebnis null zu der Quadratwurzel von P₀ * Rho * der Quadratwurzel von P₀,
alles normiert, sodass wir eine Dichtematrix erhalten. Und was uns das Gentle-Measurement-Lemma sagt, ist, dass in diesem Fall
was bedeutet, dass wir tatsächlich das wahrscheinliche Messergebnis erhalten – der Zustand, den wir erhalten, hat sich nicht sehr stark verändert von dem
ursprünglichen, und insbesondere wird das Quadrat der Fidelity notwendigerweise größer sein als 1 minus
Epsilon, und das ist toll, weil das vollkommen allgemein ist – wir haben nichts über die Messung oder
den Zustand gesagt, außer dass eines der Ergebnisse sehr wahrscheinlich ist. Das Lemma kann also in
vielen verschiedenen Situationen angewendet werden, in denen wir etwas über einen Quantenzustand überprüfen möchten, ohne ihn sehr stark zu stören. Schauen wir uns also an, wie wir das beweisen können.
Zum größten Teil ist es eigentlich eine ziemlich einfache Angelegenheit, die Fidelity zwischen dem Vor- und Nachmessungs-
zustand zu berechnen. Wir können das tun, indem wir die ursprüngliche Definition verwenden, und normalerweise könnte uns das mit einer unübersichtlichen Formel zurücklassen, aber
in diesem Fall haben wir Glück, weil das Innere der äußeren Quadratwurzel tatsächlich das Quadrat einer Matrix ist,
die positiv semidefinit ist, was das Berechnen der Quadratwurzel trivial macht. Wir können jetzt die zyklische
Eigenschaft der Spur zusammen mit der Linearität der Spur verwenden, um unseren Ausdruck zu vereinfachen, wie auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt. Beachte übrigens, dass das hier
alles Gleichheiten sind, wir haben also bis zu diesem Punkt nichts angenähert – wir vereinfachen wirklich nur. Aber jetzt brauchen wir tatsächlich eine
Ungleichung, weil wir diese Quadratwurzel im Zähler loswerden möchten, und das können wir tatsächlich tun, wenn wir uns mit einer unteren Schranke zufriedengeben. Und wenn
du an den Details für diesen Teil interessiert bist, kannst du die Ungleichung ziemlich einfach herleiten, indem du eine Spektralzerlegung von p
0 betrachtest. Die Eigenwerte von p 0 müssen zwischen 0 und 1 liegen – das gilt immer für Matrizen, die
Messungen beschreiben. Und wenn wir das wissen, folgt die Ungleichung ziemlich direkt aus der Tatsache, dass das Ziehen der Quadratwurzel von
einer Zahl zwischen 0 und 1 sie nur größer machen kann. Anders ausgedrückt: Das Quadrieren einer Zahl zwischen 0 und
1 kann sie nur kleiner machen. Wir können jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter vereinfachen und erhalten die Quadrat-
wurzel der Spur von p 0 mal Rho. Schließlich ergibt das Quadrieren beider Seiten und
Einsetzen unserer Schranke für die Wahrscheinlichkeit das, was wir wollten. Die Formel für die Fidelity
ist nicht die schönste oder einfachste Formel der Welt, aber hier funktioniert sie tatsächlich ziemlich
gut. Zum Abschluss der Lektion werfen wir einen Blick auf Uhlmanns Theorem, eine grundlegende Aussage über die Fidelity, die
sie mit dem Begriff einer Purification verbindet. Was das Theorem in einfachen Worten besagt, ist, dass die Fidelity zwischen zwei beliebigen
Quantenzuständen gleich dem maximalen Innenprodukt – im Betrag – zwischen zwei Purifications dieser
Zustände ist. Etwas detaillierter: Angenommen, Rho und Sigma sind Dichtematrizen für ein System X, und angenommen, Y ist ein
System, das mindestens so viele klassische Zustände hat wie X. Damit ist garantiert, dass beide Zustände Purifications haben, die
Quantenzustandsvektoren von XY sind. Wir können dann die Implikation des Theorems in Form der Gleichung ausdrücken,
die auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird: Die Fidelity zwischen Rho und Sigma ist gleich dem maximalen Betrag des Innenprodukts
zwischen F und Si, wobei über alle Fi und S maximiert wird, die Rho und Sigma
purificieren. Lass uns das also aufräumen und mit der präzisen mathematischen Aussage weiterarbeiten. Was wir jetzt tun werden, ist, das Theorem zu beweisen,
aber zunächst lohnt es sich, einen Moment innezuhalten und zu schätzen, dass es uns eine ziemlich intuitive Art bietet, über die
Fidelity nachzudenken. Es ist auch an sich selbst ziemlich nützlich, zum Beispiel um noch interessantere Dinge über
die Fidelity zu beweisen. Um es zu beweisen, beginnen wir mit Spektralzerlegungen unserer Dichte-
matrizen – keine Überraschungen. Sobald wir Spektralzerlegungen haben, ist es einfach,
zwei spezifische Purifications dieser Zustände zu finden. Aber hier spielen wir tatsächlich einen
Trick. Beachte, dass wir in beiden Fällen keinen Standardbasisvektor als zweiten Tensorfaktor haben, wie wir es früher in der
Lektion hatten, sondern wir haben denselben Vektor wie im ersten Tensorfaktor, nur dass er einen Balken darüber hat.
Das bedeutet das komponentenweise komplexe Konjugat dieser Vektoren. Mit anderen Worten nehmen wir im Grunde eine
zweite Kopie der Eigenvektoren, aber wir nehmen das komplexe Konjugat jedes Eintrags, und wir werden gleich sehen, warum wir das tun –
es ist überhaupt nicht offensichtlich, dass wir das tun sollten, und deshalb nennen wir es einen
Trick. In jedem Fall sind das Purifications von Rho bzw. Sigma, und das gilt aufgrund der
Tatsache, dass unsere Eigenvektoren orthonormal sind und daher auch ihre komponentenweisen komplexen Konjugate. Jetzt können wir die
unitäre Äquivalenz von Purifications anwenden, die besagt, dass jede Purification unserer zwei Zustände erhalten werden kann, indem
eine unitäre Operation auf das System angewendet wird, das herausgespurt wird. Für die spezifischen Purifications,
die wir gerade gemacht haben, müssen die unitären Operationen für die beiden Purifications nicht identisch sein,
natürlich. Daher verwenden wir hier den Buchstaben U für die erste und den Buchstaben V für die zweite.
Der Punkt ist also, dass jede Purification unserer zwei Zustände so geschrieben werden kann, wie wir es auf dem Bildschirm haben,
für irgendeine Wahl der unitären Operationen U und V. Jetzt können wir den Ausdruck
aus dem Theorem nehmen und vereinfachen. Wenn wir unsere Ausdrücke für F und S einsetzen und ein bisschen vereinfachen,
erhalten wir den Ausdruck, der hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird. Es gibt dort ein paar Schritte, und ich habe die Details nicht gezeigt –
du weißt also, was zu tun ist, wenn du es selbst machen möchtest. Aber lass mich erwähnen, dass der Grund, warum wir die Purifications so gewählt haben,
darin bestand, dieses Innenprodukt auf genau diese Weise vereinfachen zu können. Insbesondere haben wir die komplexen Konjugate
hineingetan, damit wir die Innenprodukte im zweiten Tensorfaktor effektiv umdrehen konnten, um die spezifische
Form zu erhalten, die wir genau hier haben. Wir sind fast fertig. Jetzt können wir die zyklische Eigenschaft der Spur zusammen
mit den Spektralzerlegungen, mit denen wir begonnen haben, verwenden, um diesen Ausdruck zu erhalten. Und an diesem Punkt können wir
eine der alternativen Ausdrucksmöglichkeiten für die Fidelity mithilfe der Spurnorm verwenden, und wir sind
fertig. Sicherlich gibt es Details, über die ich sehr schnell hinweggegangen bin, und es ist die Art von Beweis, den du
wirklich selbst durcharbeiten musst, um ihn vollständig zu verstehen. Aber hoffentlich gibt dir das die grundlegende
Idee, und wie üblich findest du weitere Details in den schriftlichen Inhalten zur Lektion, die in der Video-
beschreibung verlinkt sind. Und das ist das Ende der Lektion, in der es um Purifications, Fidelity und die Verbindungen zwischen ihnen ging. Es ist auch
das Ende der Einheit über die allgemeine Formulierung von Quanteninformation. Ich hoffe, du machst bei mir weiter mit
der vierten und letzten Einheit der Reihe, die über Quantenfehlerkorrektur handelt. Danke fürs Zuschauen!